Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P.
Here's kind of a weird question about my plastic
surgery background. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: I gave it to you like a media TV
type person. So I assume you've had a nose job.
I'm thinking about getting a nose job as well.
I have some issues with breathing. I have
nasal valve collapse. It doesn't happen all the
time. But sometimes at night I can't breathe out
of my left nostril. That typically happens. And
I'm just wondering, like, what your opinions are
on a just like a functional surgery like
that just to fix the nasal collapsed, like,
should I do that? Or the other thing is I'm
like way overweight for like if I lose weight,
I might not have the same issues.
And then I've heard about like doing
you can do like exercises to oh my gosh.
Speaker 1: Okay. So there's a lot going on
there. Listen, you've got to talk to an auto
larynx ologist also known as an ear, nose and
throat doctor. I have not had a nose job. Listen,
if I went and got a nose job, do you think this is
the nose I'd be asking for? That does not seem.
That does not seem appropriate. No, I have not
had a nose job. Maybe you have a deviated septum.
Who knows? But my specialty is podiatry, not ent
stuff. So you've actually got to go and talk to
a doctor. I don't know how much of this voicemail
is serious, but I know many people who have had
corrective nose surgeries, mostly deviated septum.
It was quite a recovery, took several weeks, if
not into a couple of months. And yes, I am aware
that sometimes people who have a deviated
septum will say, you know what, I think I'm
actually going to get a nose job and the
plastic surgeon can correct the deviated
septum while they're in there. Might as well do
both at once. But that is not medical advice.
I'm not Bill O'Reilly. Okay. I don't have a
concierge service where I give you all sorts of
advice. We have a fantastic bonus show today.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: You know, I can think of no
greater endorsement of the bonus show
than the fact that Alex Jones really doesn't
like it. Indiana lawmakers have approved the
first state abortion ban since Roe v
Wade was overturned. It's happening.
It's happening. U.S. automakers say that 70%
of electric vehicle models would not qualify
for the tax credit currently in the Senate bill.
Why not? I will explain. And thirdly, New Zealand
is considering changing its name to confront its
troubled colonial past. Hmm. Have they gone? Woke.
We will talk about it on today's bonus show. You
can sign up at join Pacman dot com and get instant
access. The normal prices for membership
are really low. And listen, so many of us
spend 40, 80, 120 $200 if you add up Internet
service, Netflix, some people have cable,
some people have Hulu, Discovery plus Paramount
plus Apple TV, all these different things. Some
people spend over $200 with the coupon
code Obama. You can get a membership for
two bucks a month and you're really supporting
us directly if you have a cable subscription.
Something like four bucks a month goes to Fox
News. You might hate Fox News. Okay. With the
memberships on our web site, from every dollar
we get $0.98. The other $0.02 just goes to
processing the payments. Okay. Join Pacman dot
com. Very cheap. Great perks. And you are really
you are sure you are confident that the money
is actually going where you are being told it
is going, which is into producing shows and more
content. Speaking of more content, soon I will
tell you about the new personal finance channel
that we we are launching, which I think is going
to be absolutely tremendous, folks. All right. See
you on the bonus show or otherwise back here on.